look I'm not gonna lie I'm a shooter guy
games like Mass Effect defiance and
destiny are a lot more my combat style
than the Old Republic I can't stand
using hotkeys to kill things although I
do respect that millions of other
players do through a wide range of MMOs
so when the Old Republic announced the
Knights of the Fallen Empire expansion
at e3 2015 there was a hard sell for a
four-year-old game but I never played as
a Sith so here are the top five reasons
I discovered you should go back to that
galaxy far far away
disclaimer all galaxies are far far away
number one those cutscenes blur studio
responsible for some of the most badass
cutscenes in gaming and games
advertising made cutscenes for the Old
Republic these are hands down some of
the best lightsaber duels trooper
battles bounty hunter fights and well
scripted ship combat sequences you'll
see outside of 2003's original Clone
Wars done by the creators of Samurai
Jack if you're a fan of the newer Clone
Wars or Star Wars rebels and missed
these do yourself a favor
number two it hurts be super evil I've
always wondered what would happen if the
bad guys won would they open up an evil
7-eleven and just call it a day here
have an evil Slurpee good the Sith
Academy on Korriban clearly answers that
question in an incredibly logical way
sits our Darwinistic the strong survive
the weak perish but they're also
practical don't waste your evil assets
don't kill other students unless
commanded to learn your warrior culture
and Creed in the opening sequence you're
asked to choose the fate of several
prisoners then you have to actually
justify your thought process to your
master even off to prison and torture
she remained unbroken all the more
reason to keep her alive some of the
tactics used by the Sith team to even
come right out of a CIA play book evil
after all has to be organized in focus
to make a difference in the galaxy and
isn't making a difference what really
matters
number three incredible settings and
lore yes the standard planets Alderaan
Corellia chorus on Tatooine
they're all here but so are the more
important lesser-known planets such as
Hutta Korriban Nar Shaddaa
and Tython that behind the scenes shaped
the balance of power in the Star Wars
universe not only that but being a
Bioware game these are full of
incredible sights and you get a fully
built ship to explore it with an
interior her own destiny needs it number
four I'm programmed to understand every
100 languages and dialects and in not
one is the phrase on fire positive when
referring to a person the writing is
very good as I've already mentioned I'll
tolerate classic MMO combat only for an
incredible tale I've been told by many
an Old Republic player that this title
is a fantastic single-player game and
I'm finding that to be true so far every
short fetch quest or kill quest has had
a fully voiced story behind it complete
with power plays betrayal more betrayal
and tons of evil decision-making sith
after all get promoted when they put a
saber in their masters back not only is
the writing good but it's in multiple
alien languages that really sells the
Star Wars universe my functions honor
fantasy translation Ned slaughter and
come on vacation I have an urgent
message for you from my master and
finally number 5 it's free sort of the
Old Republic constantly bugs you to
become a subscriber in menus in cantinas
in your ship at shops and apparently
your ability to run is gimped until
level 10 then there are strange things
like not being able to take off your
helmet automatically in cutscenes on the
other hand at lower levels progress
seems to go along at a fairly decent
clip I've already earned a number of XP
boosters a starting Armour package and
I'm having a lot of fun for free
actually the pricing structure gives you
a wide range of choices for example
spending as little as five dollars gets
you preferred status if you do decide to
buy a subscription you could probably
wait till September buy a 30-day pass
for $14.99 and power level with the epic
story XP boost currently active that
lets players go from level 1 to 50 only
playing class missions so those are my
top 5 reasons you should go back to the
old republic ahead of October's Knights
of the Fallen Empire expansion what are
your thoughts on the matter
is this just a long-lost MMO trying to
stay relevant or an engaging universe
with much to be explored feel free to
leave your thoughts in the comments
below and may the force be with you you
know for 13 to 15 dollars a month
you